and it's really about moving past this
it's my work or my life
um and you know people talk about
work-life balance which i hate because
it suggests that there's this seesaw so
if i get more work i have less light or
i get more light if i you know have less
work or i
worse at work and i don't think that's
true so one of the things i talked about
a lot in there was what we've just
talked about which is not obsessing
about making the right choice there's
probably no one decision that will
derail your
career
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i have with me alyssa knox aliza
built and led apac businesses for google
twitter and cloudflare prior to that she
was in banking and consulting she is now
a senior advisor for bcg a forbes
columnist and non-executive director on
both public and private boards and an
angel investor
once called a kick-ass woman slaying the
world of tech aliza is the author of
don't quit your day job outlining six
mind shifts you need to rise and thrive
at work as part of her commitment to
empowering the next generation of
leaders
recently listed in the top 100 women in
tech she's also been named the i.t woman
of the year
alisa knox welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me all the
way from singapore now right
yep i've been sitting in singapore where
it's almost midnight
well first of all thank you very much
for your commitment to sharing your
passion and curiosity
at least to this show and i'm really
excited to tell a little bit about your
story the new book that that you've
written which really talks about
something that is very
uh
pertinent in in today's society and the
different things that are going on about
quitting our day jobs and what does it
mean to love our life and work and
everything in between but but first a
little bit about your your background i
mean you've held some of the most
interesting positions at
if i had to list all the companies that
i would want to work for you've pretty
much
been an executive position in all of
them so not just hopped around but
really made a meaningful impact and
later on set in some some great
executive boards and and and also
lecturing in academia and teaching about
business and so a lot of really i'm sure
a lot of fascinating things to talk
about but elisa if you're looking at
your own trajectory
what do you really enjoy about your work
what has sort of been sort of the
guiding force for you throughout your
career
the thing that i enjoy most if i look
back where i get the most pleasure was
having
um helped develop other people i don't
want to say on motherhood you were like
i'm the saint i mean i'm not i like to
hate goals as much as much as the next
person i'm like writing revenue i like
seeing clients
but when i talk about the
more than 40 years that i was in the
corporate world which just finished a
little over a year ago
when i hear myself talk
what was most fulfilling
was helping people
get to the next stage of their career
maybe faster or maybe thinking more
broadly about their careers so
for example
i had several people
work for me as executive assistants at
google and there's nothing wrong with
being an ea and for some of people it's
a great career but a lot of these people
like they had master's degrees they just
graduated from college
they seemed driven i was surprised that
they wanted to be
an assistant um one of them was part of
a program where google said well we're
just bringing people in because we know
they're smart but they don't know what
they want to do yet
and give them a shot at different things
another one said to me well i've been um
doing event organizing at a university
in singapore
but
i think i want to be an ea and i was
like you you have this master's degree
in east asian studies what i'm i'm not
sure
that you know this is the most you can
do
so the first one
um
runs products or part of product
appellanteer the second one is running a
sales team at blank dance
i think both of these people could have
gotten to where they are without me
maybe it would have been a bit slower
maybe it would have been slightly
different and there's lots more examples
like that not because i'm so amazing but
because i've had the chance to work with
a lot of people and
you know as i look back that's what has
really driven me the most that's my
passion
incredible and if you're looking at
sort of the way that you're thinking
more holistically about work and life
and meaning right i mean a lot of this
book i think we can talk about you know
deriving meaning and where where are we
at in in this whole constellation
where did you find yourself in in your
own career what was your
guiding curiosity as you're working with
these different organizations
well it's funny you used the word
curiosity because i would have said my
guiding principle was curiosity so i
kind of
in retrospect having worked in tech i
divide my career into
um three software releases at least so
far so 1.0 was boston consulting group
and some financial services companies
2.0 was google twitter cloudflare and
3.0 is what i'm doing now which is
sitting on boards which i started at 2.0
and
writing this book don't quit your day
job and
doing having more time to do um some
sort of
mentoring i think a lot of people come
to talk to me either because um i'm been
a woman in tech woman in sales maybe
just because i've worked so long
um but
it's interesting because the thing
that's driven me is more curiosity i
left consulting because
people kept saying well you won't get to
if you don't leave pretty soon you won't
get to be an operator you won't know how
to do how to write a p pnl and pretty
soon no one will let you do that i was
like well
or maybe you could say it's fomo you
know
either curiosity or fear missing out
well gosh how do i know if i want to do
that if i don't do it like i better try
it and then
um i was living in the bay area during
the first.com boom and that bust i was
at visa at the time
and i kept thinking hey i'm missing out
on this internet thing you know what's
going on here like i know these people
who are starting in it are younger than
i am but
i think like i'm i'm missing out and i
met did cerf who was one of the founders
of the internet and i met him at a
business meeting when i was at diva and
thought about it and
later considered it with serendipity and
so i said to him hey you know i really
like financial services and i definitely
haven't mastered it but i want to know
what's going on
with this with this internet and with
like online media i don't know anything
about it would you guys talk to me that
eventually led my going to am i going to
tick
um google and twitter both sort of
online media although some differences
and then cloudflare
called me and um
said
you know would you consider talking to
us and i was thinking well i've done a
couple start
you know businesses in asia for american
companies american tech companies maybe
that's not so interesting to do again
but then when i got to understand
cloudflare and learned it was all about
internet performance and security which
i knew nothing about i was like hey this
is great i want to learn about this
so i would have to say
the word you used before i got to it
curiosity has been my driving factor and
at one point when i made the switch to
google which involved
a
a significant title reduction because
financial services titles were probably
pretty inflated and tech titles were not
yet
and some trade-offs on salary versus
equity which
obviously paid itself
back but i didn't know at the time
i had a very senior well-respected
executive search person in the valley
tell me that i was
brave
in quotes which i think amid
foolhardy possibly stupid
and um so it wasn't it wasn't linear but
it was just driven by
i mean obviously i still wanted to make
a living but i wanted to do things that
were interesting to me
it it seems like a pretty lonely
decision to make
you're you're doing you're you have a
trajectory you're doing very well you're
rising sort of in the ranks if you will
and this sort of this game that that has
been constructed in a lot of these
industries and and at some point you you
take this brave action of
taking a title reduction changing the
way you're thinking about compensation
and um
was that a you know was that an easy
decision because it doesn't sound like
it it is
to be guided by curiosity to the point
where you're changing career
trajectories
yeah i think it was a little scary um
i suppose that i'd get
bored doing one thing all the time and
you know it was a great and maybe i
learned that in consulting where you
know you worked for one company for a
while and moved to another one and so
you
have this incredible
um variety of things that you get to do
so maybe i was spoiled by that
um or maybe i have adult add i don't
know but i like this idea of learning
different things so yeah i don't think
it's for everybody because i did make
some trade-offs in title and
just you know linear trajectory
but if i look back
i'm really happy with how it's turned
out for example
almost all of the board seats
um that i've gotten are because i
have some exposure to 10 i'm not sure if
i would have gotten them
from consulting maybe from financial
services
um
but on the other hand you know i look at
some of my friends who've stayed at bcg
they're both careers and they've had
fantastic careers so it's not like i
look back and say it's great that i left
it's just
what i did turned out to be good and i
think one of the interesting things i
know you mentioned you know you talk to
a lot of your friends at stanford and
for
younger people i do
a lot of you know talking to people of
various ages and one of the things i
find is that some people really
stress over these decisions and of
course moving companies is a big
decision you should have some
thought and some stress but at a certain
point you need to just kind of go with
it because i think for most people these
steps are going to work out you know you
take a plunge
you go with it and it's probably going
to be it's probably going to be okay you
know and
i don't know that there are that many
really wrong decisions and i i've made
two decisions where
you know i really didn't like the job
and left in less than a year you could
look back and say
that was a terrible decision
or you could say
that this the first one i made was going
from
my bank training program right after
college to american express
worked for this fantastic woman who came
to recruit me
after i'd done an mba at night and then
she left right after i got there and i
was left with no advocates in the plays
you know very difficult situation
and lasted about nine months and i just
thought like this is really too hard
life isn't meant to be like
but it propelled me to do something
which i had bought about for a long time
which was to to
move internationally i really wanted to
live overseas
i didn't really have any language skills
i'd still don't sadly
um i'd been to england during college
cold rainy soggy vegetables you know i
think it's better now but i didn't want
to go back
and um
so i looked on a map
figured that australia was close to asia
i'd always been interested in asia but
didn't have
um language skills and
i probably could have gone to hong kong
racing for but didn't realize it and
i motivated myself to find a job in
australia
so if i hadn't taken the job that i
didn't like
who knows where i would be now because
that job in australia was pcg and then
it led on to from one great thing to
another
that's incredible i love that
tell me a little bit about
this book
don't quit your day job six mind shifts
to rise and thrive at work
what is that about
i would love to tell you about my book
we could be here all day i know we're
limited um the first thing i want to say
is the book is not never ever resign
never quit that's not what it's
meant to be it's just six mind shifts to
rise and thrive is too long for title
and you know they're publishers involved
and it is a good kind of controversial
title for the great resignation of the
great reset or the gravy shuffle
whatever we're in now
it's really meant more to say that
oftentimes
um as people think about leaving jobs or
changing their careers they're probably
not thinking about it with the right
mindset
and that if i can help people think
about
different perspectives sometimes that
will cause them to leave their job but
sometimes it'll cause them to do other
things like find outside passion
and
you know for the people who are leaving
now
uh i read that
linkedin
wall street journal quoted linkedin as
saying that four and a half percent of
all
new hires during the great resignation
last year have already boomeranged back
to their old company
right
so
it's not always the right solution
to resign and particularly
if you're leaving something as opposed
to going to something like if you're
resigning because you're running away or
you want to have you know amy cuddy
talks about it
and somebody on one of your prior
podcasts talked about it too about
people saying
it's not a resignation it's a great you
know
um
go shove it to your employer and so that
gives you that great burst of energy
right now
but that might not be the right reason
to leave
put yourself somewhere else you know you
feel that that power so
the book is about these six mind shifts
and um
kim scott you guys might have heard of
who wrote radical candor and has written
some other books now as well
um and whom i know from google had said
you know the book proves that minds not
just passion but mindsets drive career
success and that's why i wrote it the
mind chips in the book are timeless
and having worked for four decades i
thought
and having being sought out a lot
for sort of coffee mentoring
which is
great but difficult because i don't love
coffee and you know there's
only so many hours in the day and
there's one thing you learn in tech it's
that you have to be scaled so
one-on-ones are not skinned
i thought i'd write it down
so if you want i can go through some of
the mind chips and we could that would
be awesome let's do it
okay
so
um the first one is you're working your
life are on the same team
it's actually start to go for both
because of that and
it's really about moving past this it's
my work or my life
um and you know people talk about
work-life balance which i hate because
it suggests that there's this see-saw so
if i get more work i have less light or
i get more life i
you know have less work or i do worse at
work and i don't think that's true so
one of the things i talked about a lot
in there was what we've just talked
about which is not obsessing about
making the right choice there's probably
no one decision that will derail your
career
and so each mind shift has four power
perspectives and then a bunch of
examples
and then
four or five actionable takeaways
and
in to back each of these up not
scientifically but empirically there are
lots and lots of anecdotes of i think
three dozen people probably 60 women 40
men
different ethnicities different parts of
the world
age range from 21 to early 60s so
hopefully
if you get around to reading it you'll
see that there's somebody you can
identify maybe not everybody
so and there's another example there's a
um
it's pretty similar so i'll go through
quickly but emily rubin a friend of one
of my children who just graduated from
college couldn't find a job during covet
took when she wasn't so sure about it a
startup in san francisco
liked it in the beginning then
a lot of reworks and um found herself
pretty unhappy
i thought she should try to stay for a
year you know usually that like it used
to be when i started working five years
you need to stay for five years to prove
that you're a committed person and i
think that's really changed which is
great
but like maybe a year to learn it but
she couldn't
she just couldn't put up with the
situation and she got a job at a
mid-sized consulting company that you
might have heard of called huron and she
loves it and what's really interesting
is that
even though she'd only worked about nine
months she'd moved from the east coast
to the west coast and she'd had this
experience and those two things had put
her in touch with and gave her the
credibility to get prior to hiro
so again
you know she made a decision
um
and
it didn't work and she was able to to
move on
um another quick quick story from me
which i think is funny and there are
other funny stories in there too is i
got an mba at night at nyu
so for those of you at stanford you know
kudos to you for being at that amazing
school on the west coast
and i did it because
i was working in new york and there was
nowhere to swim
and that was how i used to exercise i
have since moved beyond that i have a
couple other things i can do at the gym
or play badminton but i was all i knew
how to do couldn't get into a pool
lived in the village only way i could
get into this brand new pool was to take
classes at nyu
and i did it with a friend and four
years later like it was i wanted to go
to stanford she learned to go to harvard
um you know we're like we're gonna take
a couple classes and get credit and
voila four years later
not enough sleep apartments smelled like
chlorine but nba in hand
and because i had done that because i
didn't make the trade-off between work
and life i'm like i'm gonna have this
thing that i want in my life
even though it's not so great because
i'm taking classes when i'm also working
and it's kind of a you know it wasn't
the easiest thing to do
i did it and then voila when i wanted to
move to australia bcg was like oh do you
have an mba i'm like well yes i haven't
eaten because i just did this know that
i could swim
so i didn't make those trade-offs
between work and life i made some other
trade-offs like maybe not enough sleep
and
it you know i could have never imagined
that that was what was gonna happen that
is so what is the more underlying
lesson to be learned here about thinking
through trade-offs
when we come to college they tell us
that i believe the triangle is you can
choose there's there's sleep
there's work and there's social life
and you have you can only choose two out
of those three
and i think that's usually one of the
first sentences they tell a college
student um but but but your lesson
teaches something a little also even
though you did mention you lost some
sleep but but what what is the
underlying lesson on trade-offs there
i think the
underlying lesson is you don't
necessarily have to make the trade-offs
that you think
um i wrote an article in forbes a couple
months ago about a journalist who
thought she had to make these trade-offs
of living in small town america she went
to colombia which is
you know like the preeminent colombian
northwestern preeminent journalism
school in the us
thought she had to make the trade off of
living in small towns to cover
really important issues
but really wanted to be in new york gave
that up gave off gave up the small town
stuff because
in order to do this thing she wanted in
her life to be in new york and maybe it
took a few years
longer but she's at the wall street
journal now which was awful to begin
with
so
i think the trade-off is that or the the
way to think about it is
if there are things you really care
about in your life you probably need to
do that and you can't always predict it
but likely the fact that you're happier
the fact that those things are important
to you are giving you what you want the
sustenance the personal sustenancy more
means that you will likely end up being
able to go where you want with your
careers i love it elisa this is a i know
just the tip of the iceberg from from
many more
interesting insights uh from your book
but but even more from your career and i
really want to thank you and for the
time that you've that you've been here i
can't believe that it's
i think past midnight at this point for
you and i really really appreciate
the willingness and the time and the
energy and for all the great work and i
look forward to reading the book myself
and thank you very much elisa this was
awesome
thanks for giving me honor i guess um
you since it's after midnight you know
the trade-offs i've been making 100 100
thank you very much